FLOWERS: 270 started
in about 1970.
At that time, our
department head
was in charge of the
first design course--
Herb Richardson.
And we gave the students
a creativity kit.
And I was a graduate
student at the time
and worked closely
with the students
and learned that, for
their first design project,
it was really hard for
them to decide what to do.
So the next year, we
decided that we'd give them
a kit of materials but give
them a very specific thing
to try to accomplish.
And they got into
it immediately,
and that sort of got
the ball rolling.
And 270 began with a
very simple contest
that involved making
the machine go down
a hill in three minutes.
Back then, we had about
30 students in the class,
and maybe another
15 or 20 people
came to watch the contest.
And it happened in
one of our classrooms.
It was a very modest beginning.
Actually, the genesis of the
design-and-build part of 270
came from noticing that
most kids had never
really designed and built and
seen Mother Nature evaluate
something.
So we thought that the
design process would best
be illustrated by getting
them in there and doing it.
The thing that's kind
of different about 270
is that it was born
a little premature.
We started doing it before
other folks got into it.
But it grew up really strong.
And it grew up with
a great attitude.
The students here make
the contest what it is,
and they go at it with an
enthusiasm and a commitment
and a sense of
helping one another
that's wonderfully unique.
I think the thing that makes
the 270 experience quite unique
is that, for most
of the students,
they've never done a
really public demonstration
of their ability to conceive
something and build it.
And they kind of give
birth to something.
And they watch it as it
goes out and does its task.
And that's done in a very
celebratory environment.
The students all know
that we'll still love them
if the machine doesn't work.
But it's done under a
great deal of pressure.
So the mix of pressure
and forgiveness,
and the process of really doing
something, is a great mix.
One of the things that's
important about 270
is that it comes at the end of
a great deal of expectation.
The students have
seen it on television.
They know about it.
They think about it in advance.
And they get into
it, and it ends up
being a really exciting
thing to do, for some reason
that I don't really understand.
But building something and
launching it out into the world
and having it do
is really exciting.
So they think about it a lot.
They work on it really hard.
And after it's over,
there's a tremendous feeling
of satisfaction and relief.
And that's an important
event in one's life.
One of the ways to think
about why 270 is important
is to look at Thomas Massie.
Thomas came to MIT because when
he was in the seventh grade,
he saw the 270 contest
on television and said,
I want to go win that.
And he came to MIT
as he was a senior
in electrical engineering.
He took the course
and won the contest.
Obviously, lots of kids
think about doing that.
It's a big deal.
One of the things
that's happened
is that the culture
of the course
has evolved in a way
that helping one another
is one of the core ideas.
That came from the students, and
we have allowed it to flourish,
and it's now part of
the core tradition.
They learn from
one another a lot
more than they learn from us.
And I really like
seeing that happen.
You know, the thing that's
really important about the 270
deal is that it's a
shared commitment.
The students hear from
the staff and the faculty
that we're going to work hard
to make this thing work well.
We're going to put
a lot of energy
into defining the contests
so that it's interesting.
And we're going to work hard
to support you and help you.
And the students
respond to that.
And they work hard, and
they put a lot into it.
And that deal, where
everyone is agreeing
that this is
something important,
is the key ingredient
that makes it work.
I think one of the really
nice features of the course
is that it gives the
students an opportunity
to remodel themselves.
They discover that
they can, in fact,
take a chaotic kit of materials
and use their creativity
and make something
wonderful happen.
And if you trust
your own creativity,
you're very likely to have
a more satisfying life
than otherwise.
I think, probably, the single
most important ingredient
of a good contest
is to make sure
that it has been
ambivalence-scaled right,
so that even the staff
or the people that
conceived the contest have no
idea what's the best solution.
So if you balance
things properly, then
among the people that
are talking about it,
there's a heavy argument
about which way to go.
That drives diverse solutions.
In fact, one of the contests
that I designed some years ago,
called The Potentially
Great Race,
was terrible because all
the solutions looked alike.
It was optimizable.
It was predictable.
And I just didn't
see that in advance.
One of my favorite 270
stories centers around a slide
that I have of a student
looking at her machine
as it goes over the top
of a sand-covered hill.
And it's important because she
had come to my office crying.
I hate this course.
This is terrible.
I've never built anything.
I'm not going to make a
good grade, et cetera.
And she hung in there,
did it, her machine
did what she wanted it to do.
And she ended up
becoming a designer.
I like that story.
The 270 contest evolved
to where it is today.
When we first started,
it was a simple machine
doing a single thing
while people watched.
And it was quite slow.
After a while, we had machines,
side by side, doing things,
so you could see
some competition.
And then, we got
interested in, what
happens if the machines
actually collide in the middle
and compete for territory?
And from that, we evolved
robotically-controlled things,
so that they were not
automatic, that students
were controlling them while
they were doing things.
And that has become a much more
interactive, interesting thing
to watch.
Actually, I have two favorites.
One was called
The Harvest, which
involved a wavy table
and 300 ping-pong balls.
And it was really a
wonderfully dramatic contest
because of the diverse ways
the students approached it.
The other was called The Summit
Meeting, which was a mountain
and involved raising
a ping-pong ball
high over the summit
of the mountain.
And the students built
wonderful, tall towers
and diverse machines.
And they both just worked well.
We all want to be happy.
Wise people have
pointed out that you
can't make people happy by
taking away the things that
make them unhappy.
In this course,
many students learn
that they can become happy
through the satisfaction
of being creative.
And that's really
a wonderful lesson.
Mother Nature applies all of
her rules all of the time.